Fresh cranberries can be bounced like a rubber
ball.
Luna moths have no mouths; they live off the
energy they stored when they were a caterpillar.
A study found that women look their oldest
at 3:30pm every Wednesday.
This is because this is when women are typically
under the most stress at work and have the
lowest energy levels.
When the moon is directly overhead, you weigh
slightly less.
At birth, Polar bear can weigh as little as
500 grams, so small that you can hold in one
in your hands.
But at maturity, Polar bears can weigh as
much as 500 kgs.
Who owns space?
No one - The Outer Space Treaty, signed by
all major space faring nations, prohibits
claiming territory in space or on celestial
bodies.
Space is considered “the shared heritage
of mankind”.
You can start a fire with ice.
In the U.S., if you find a bald eagle feather
on the ground, you need a permit to pick it
up.
The sun evaporates about a trillion tons of
water a day.
Whenever a pregnant women suffers from organ
damage like a heart attack, the foetus sends
stem cells to the organ helping it to repair.
Women can get pregnant while they're already
pregnant.
This rare phenomenon is called superfetation.
The ashes of one in 50 people who are cremated
are never collected by relatives.
Disney Parks developed a paint colour that's
meant to help things visually disappear by
tricking the eye into ignoring it.
They named it “Go Away Green” - a bland,
natural blue-green colour used on unsightly
park structures like fences, garbage bins
and admin buildings to help them blend in
with the landscape.
An attosecond is one billionth of a billionth
of a second.
Dogs and elephants are the only animals that
understand pointing.
France is no longer the world's biggest wine
producer, Italy has overtaken it.